the Joe Rogan experience we [ __ ] that
up
we thought we were recording we were
saying how Burt is the only person we
know who's both funny and a great
promoter like usually get one or the
other you get someone who's really funny
but we're talking about Burt's we saw
all this room record with so much better
video is being recorded
oh I'm just that video so I can leave
that in the mp3 or breaking download
that everybody the audio we're gonna
stop now we're here the double repeater
sauce so a bunch of people birdies to
have a show called Burt hurt Burt and
that one disturbed me the most because
remember this one of the whole Burt he
would do a bunch of stupid [ __ ] and get
injured but he's really getting hurt
he's dude you just see with some kid and
some red belt kid who's with health and
grill Hori and Gracie really that night
when he was that young he really reminds
me of that frat guy yeah but he was I
can't really see it now but this is him
like four years removed from that this
guy keeps armbar and I mean here's know
what to do here kiss 108 pounds I think
part of it is also going along with it
enjoying he's got to take the offensive
[ __ ] that wow this kid I'll never see it
he's played duck twice possum twice a
video that I showed you that Bridget
fantasy showed me it's a video of this
guy who's on a school bus and it just it
start to the bus driver rolling a little
kid off the school bus screaming Adam
and then a bunch of people like what the
[ __ ] are you doing man you chase it back
onto the bus the bus driver gets back on
the bus and then they check not are you
okay and they realize this little kid
with like a lunchbox and everything was
actually a grown [ __ ] and he's
pretending that he's a little kid
hanging out with these little kids and
the bus driver found it through the look
at everybody's faith with like when they
say wait he's not a kid and they're all
yeah oh I was mad lunchbox
he throws out his lunchbox and he grabs
them throws them yeah it's crazy
cuz he's got a little bit of a disaster
be the bus drivers ass so I'm Chuck off
a little kid five-year olds body people
read his car the cops yeah and then they
get to him to see hey you okay
now watch this they go that's a
grown-ass man
sure a dude was pretending to be
everyone's confused look how confused I
was mad before I don't know what to
think now that's crazy they thought okay
there's a David Blaine that's crazy why
did we bring that up why were we talking
about that that's a great question
that's not a do it's nothing to do with
burp I don't know what that was what
it's what I did no no no a kid the kid
was beating up her in jujitsu I don't
remember to November yeah this is not
sober November
[Applause]